[Music]
thank you
welcome to another episode of what's up
Prof
hello Walter Martin how are you doing
Walter
we're hanging on I'm hanging on life
because it's chaotic it's not that it's
bad but it's just chaotic yeah it's I
think it's your fault
well if it is I'm sorry
the point where you either decide you're
gonna cry or you can laugh so you might
as well laugh so what's the point of
crying we will just put it out in
laughter yes so
one of the subjects that
is a hard subject for some to
to Fathom yes we're going to talk about
tradition the bane of religion
and you know we're living in in a Time
where tradition within the church and
Traditional Values within Society are in
Collision yeah
and we have to look at it I think and we
have to ask the Lord for protection or
through this discussion so let's pray
Heavenly Father we thank you for being
able to do this discussion
Lord help us to bring the message that
you want to bring and Enlighten
everybody's Minds with the Holy Spirit
in Jesus name amen amen
now why is this an important subject
because as a consequence of tradition
many will be lost
that's exactly what the Bible says and
we have to bring a message of warning to
the world so
we have to look at what this is all
about
so what does Bane really mean
if you look it up in the dictionary it
says it's a cause of great distress or
annoyance
the telephone was the bane of my life as
an example but there's an archaic
meaning as well which is something
especially poison which causes death
I thought that was very appropriate I
think that's one that the Bible is
actually well this tradition is actually
referring to yes so when we're talking
about tradition being the bane of
religion it's a it's a poison and it
causes death
and besides that it's annoying yeah it
is because people cling to it so if it
were a multiple choice we would say all
of the above that's it
all right so let's have a look at why
tradition is the bane of religion and
why we should be on our God concerning
it
let's look at the verses in Matthew 5
Christ came to fulfill the law think not
that I am come to destroy the law
or the prophets I'm not come to destroy
but to fulfill
for verily I sent you till Heaven and
Earth pass one jotto one Tittle shall in
no wise pass from the Lord till all be
fulfilled
whosoever therefore shall break one of
the least Commandments
and shall teach men so he shall be
called the least in the Kingdom of
Heaven now interesting later on in the
parallel verses it actually says you
won't be there yeah
so it's not good to be the least because
you won't be there you won't be even
spoken of yes in this situation but
whosoever shall do and teach them
the same Shall be Called great in the
Kingdom of Heaven for I say unto you
that accept your righteousness shall
exceed the righteousness of the scribes
and Pharisees
you shall in no case enter into the
kingdom of heaven now this must have
given the disciples an apoplectic fit
yeah because
the Pharisees and the scribes were
everything they were the example they
were the ultimate
and here they are being told that unless
their righteousness exceeds that of the
scribes and Pharisees
usually no case enter into the kingdom
of heaven now the interesting thing is
Martin how much righteousness do we have
zero
so Martin if your righteousness and if
you have none has to exceed those of the
scribes and Pharisees
then there seems to be a problem right
yeah you cannot you cannot you cannot so
the righteousness that we're speaking
about here must be an imputed and
imparted righteousness that's it can we
therefore deduce from that that the
scribes and the Pharisees had no imputed
and imparted righteousness exactly they
had their own self-righteousness ah so
that there's the problem right they had
their righteousness
and that is the problem because we can't
boast of any righteousness of our own so
if our righteousness is to exceed that
of the Pharisees then it must be an
extraneous righteousness an alien
righteousness as Martin Luther called it
and now the problem is the Pharisees and
and scribes there's this
self-righteousness seemed like the
correct righteousness to the people
but it was
the bane of religion
so let's go to a spirit of Prophecy
quote the law of God unmixed with human
tradition
was presented by Christ as the great
standard of obedience
and this aroused the enmity of the
rabbis they had said human teaching
above God's word
and I turned the people away from his
precepts what
is it possible that modern scribes and
Pharisees
can place human Traditions above us as
the Lord
it's not only possible it's happening
all the time okay
they had said human teachings above
God's word and had turned the people
away from his precepts they would not
give up their man-made Commandments in
order to obey the requirements of the
word of God
that's a very serious allegation
modern do some of our people have a
propensity to introduce requirements
which are contrary to the word of God
but which are presented as part and
parcel of the word of God yes constantly
constantly right the whole time people
us and that's a thing so you like the
scribes though that righteousness that
everybody's seen people today say the
same they also at man-made Commandments
and now today the scribes and Pharisees
and that so leaders of churches and
everything do the same I do the same
they would not for the truth sake
sacrifice the pride of reason and the
prayers of men
when Christ came presenting to the
Nations the claims of God
the priests and Elders denied his right
to interpose between them and the people
they would not accept these rebukes and
warnings and they set themselves to turn
the people against him and to Compass
his destruction
so do we face a similar situation today
absolutely
you know I
I really don't want to even talk about
some of these issues but if you take the
woke issue
has it infiltrated our churches yes now
the church isn't it to be a place where
God's requirements are accepted and
adhered to yes and uphealth and upheld
so the church should be a filter to keep
that which is wrong outside of its Gates
the Commandments not the man right once
the one from God is a hedge so that is
supposed to keep that out and the good
in so if the common tradition of
humanity says no we have to embrace it
does that mean The Church Must embrace
it as well especially not the church
okay enough said right definitely
Matthew 15 verse 8 this people draws
nigh unto me with their mouth and
honoreth me with their lips but their
hearts are far from me
but in vain they do worship me teaching
for doctrines the Commandments of men
it's a very
strong word in vain
it means it's useless it's for naught it
goes in and end with not all that says
Lord Lord will go in
okay now it's interesting if you go to
verse 2 from Matthew
what gave rise to this was the disciples
that apparently transgressed the
traditions of the elders
so they asked Jesus why do thy disciples
transgress the traditions of the elders
for they wash not their hands when they
eat bread
but he answered and said unto them why
do ye also transgress the Commandments
of God by your tradition
and honor not his father or his mother
he shall be free thus have ye made the
Commandment of God of none effect by
your tradition
so Jesus rebukes them and says they have
put their tradition above the word of
God
so they think they are doing God's will
yes but they're blind to their own
self-righteousness now God had given an
obligation to the children to take care
of their parents when they were frail
and old and the Pharisees had said no if
you give the money to the cause of the
temple and to the scribes and the
Pharisees then you're freed from that
obligation that's breaking God's law
that's it and and it seems you see if
you explain it like that
it might seem small
in but it's still breaking God's law and
it might seem righteous because you're
giving the money to the church exactly
Mark 7 verse 3 for the Pharisees and all
the Jews except they wash their hands
oft eat not holding the tradition of the
elders so there was an external
traditionality you had to do certain
things you had to go through certain
rituals and if you didn't perform them
then you were not seen to be righteous
verse 5 then the Pharisees and scribes
asked him why walk not thy disciples
according to the tradition of the elders
but eat bread with unwashed hands for
laying aside says verse 8 the
Commandment of God ye hold the
traditions of men
as the washing of pots and cups and many
other such things you do so it wasn't
just one issue there were many issues
but all of it came back to something
they were doing always something they
were doing
and he said unto them full well you
reject the Commandment of God that you
may keep your own tradition
making the word of God of none effect
through your tradition which you have
delivered and many such like things you
do you're making the word of God of
non-effect
that's a very serious allegation so a
tradition
or a view that is commonly accepted and
has become traditionally accepted coming
into the church can make
the word of God of non-effect
so it actually can lead people
away from God without them even knowing
it
all right Colossians 2 verse 8 says
beware lest any man spoil you through
philosophy
and vain deceit after the tradition of
men after the rudiments of the world and
not of the Christ so there's more to it
than just church tradition
exactly the world what the world teaches
what their philosophy is on certain
issues has no room in God's church and
that will get you probably a few of
these things still but that includes a
lot of barriers like music and all of
these things
okay now Martin what sets the standard
in the church
God's word God's word is the standard
that is the absolute pure standard
that's the way it should be in the
church anything that contradicts God's
word
should be kept out of the church
now everybody
in the world contradicts God's word
isn't that right that's it but when they
come into the church mustn't they leave
that behind that you get washed of that
all right or must the church accept it
and it become acceptable in the church
no that's exactly the problem so do you
lower the standard of God's word no
okay
so let's call it by its right name let's
call it sin because anything that is
contrary to God's word is sin so
tradition
that is against What God Says in his
word is sin
sin is this loyalty to God
and is deserving of punishment
fig leaves so together have been
employed since the days of Adam yet the
nakedness of the soul of The Sinner is
not covered
all the arguments piece together by all
who have interested themselves in this
flimsy robe will come to naught isn't
that beautiful important
sin is the transgression of the law
Christ was manifest in our world to take
away transgression and sin and to
substitute for the covering of fig
leaves the pure Robes of his
righteousness
the law of God stands Vindicated by the
suffering and death of the only begotten
son of the infinite God
so only the robe of righteousness that
we get from Christ will do the Fig Leaf
won't do yeah what is a masonic apron
yeah it's covering like a fig Leaf it's
a fake Leaf yes it might not be as
scratchy as the Fig Leaf wasn't but it's
nevertheless a fig Leaf that's all it is
in other words it's a official
proclamation of standing in your own
righteousness you cannot get it any
blatant more blatant okay it's actually
an affront to God yeah well that's what
we've that's actually sin it's sin yes
2 Corinthians 6 1. we then as workers
together with him beseech you also that
you receive not the grace of God in vain
so Martin can you receive it in vain if
you stick to the
Traditions yeah can I ask a question
quickly how much does tradition link
into culture
often it is part and parcel of the same
thing so you have to be very careful
because a lot of people say okay but
that's their culture that's his culture
if it links to tradition and it's
against what the word says that's in the
same category he falls into sin now in
the German culture i spine on sauerkraut
is part and part of the culture
you can stick to the sauerkraut but you
have to get rid of the eye spine which
is
contrary to the word of God right you
see and I think and that's one of the
hardest things to do is when it goes to
Culture Your tradition it's a heart
getting rid of some of the things yes
well if you take In some cultures if you
change for instance your religion you
are worked out of the community at all
and they don't want to accept you yes
and there are certain things which are
highly biblical
which if you do not accept in certain
cultures makes you
total outcast in in that Society
especially in very traditional societies
like African societies for example
now if we go back to the Bible Paul
called by God of the persecuted the
church for the sake of tradition
so is it possible that tradition can
become so important that you will
persecute God's people for not keeping
it yes you will kill for it didn't they
crucify Christ because of it exactly and
the disciples all of them were killed
for the same reason
all right
but I certify you Brethren that the
gospel which was preached of me is not
of the man for I neither received it of
man neither was I taught it but the
revelation of Jesus Christ
so he received direct Revelations from
Christ
for you have heard of my conversation in
time past in the Jews religion
now that beyond measure I persecuted the
Church of God and wasted it
and profited in the Jews religion above
many of my equals in my own Nation being
more exceedingly zealous of the
tradition of my fathers
so the tradition drove him to persecute
God's people and he was thinking he's
doing it
for God I was thinking he was righteous
so if your righteousness didn't exceed
this righteousness you were lost
but when it pleased God who separated me
from my mother's womb and called me by
his grace to reveal his son in me
that I might preach him amongst the
Heathen immediately I conferred not with
flesh and blood neither went I up to
Jerusalem to them which were Apostles
before me but I went into Arabia and
returned again unto a Damascus then
after three years I went up to Jerusalem
to see Peter and Abode with him 15 days
but other of the Apostles saw a nun
saved James the Lord's brother so he
says I didn't get it from anyone but God
himself
and everything that he discovered
in the Old Testament
suddenly came to life
and his tradition became useless and
valueless now now if you remember he's
talking to the Galatians so these guys
are keeping hanging on to tradition yes
and they don't want to accept him
actually as an apostle they're actually
moaning about because Jesus told him to
that the tradition has to go it's
actually very funny it's very hard and
was it easy to convince the disciples by
the way yeah I mean if we go to that
part even after they decided okay we
won't go with this tradition anymore
and James and James they catch them oh
no they just fell a little bit back into
it
priests and scribes and rulers were
fixed in a rut of Ceremonies and
traditions their hearts had become
contracted like the dried up wine skins
to which he had compared them
while they remained satisfied with the
legal religion it was impossible for
them to become depositories of the
Living Truth of Heaven
they thought their own righteousness all
sufficient we have to talk a little bit
more about this righteousness Martin
and did not desire that a new element
should be brought into their religion
the good will of God to men they did not
accept as something apart from
themselves they connected it with their
own Merit because of their good works
the Bible says all our good works of
filthy rags
the faith that works by love and
purifies the soul could find no place
for Union with the religion of the
Pharisees
made up of Ceremonies and the
injunctions of men
the effort to unite the teachings of
Jesus with the established religion
would be vain impossible
the one has to give way to the other you
can only pour the new wine into new wine
skins the old ones will have to rupture
they will have to disappear they'll have
to be thrown away they cannot be any
mixing or mingling so that old vessel
which is really you and me has to go
so what does that mean for anybody who
accepts truth when it comes into the
church can he bring his old wine skin
with him no and then say listen this is
how God made me please accept me like
this or else no no no no no
like that one Pastor in Europe he says
he wants to change the church
what does he want to do does he want to
change the word of God for the sake of
his tradition yes that's exactly what
they want to do
okay so it's actually van Martin
the vital truth of God like fermenting
wine would burst the old decaying
bottles of the pharisaical tradition
and this is where we are in the world
today it's a very dangerous place and
the church is in a crisis it's treading
on a very dangerous precipice
the people whom God had called to be the
pillar and ground of the truth
had become representatives of Satan now
when it comes to the work issues the
leaders say that do not have the right
to dictate to individual churches or
conferences and they can do as they
please
but are the leaders the standard or is
the word of God the standard what is the
standard is the standard
the word of God okay what does the word
of God say you how do you treat this so
when you go against the word of God and
say you have to accept this whatever is
they're bringing in
then you become a representative of
Satan
they were doing the work that he desired
them to do taking a course to
misrepresent the character of God and
cause the world to look upon him as a
tyrant
the very priests who ministered in the
temple had lost sight of the
significance of the service they
performed they had ceased to look beyond
the symbol to the things signified
in presenting the sacrificial offerings
they were as actors in a play
the ordinances which God himself had
appointed were made to the means of
blinding the minds and hardening the
hearts
God could do no more for man through
these channels the whole system
must be swept away
so this is talking about the sacrificial
system
they used it as a ritual and now isn't
can you not see God had to take it away
because people didn't understand what it
was about anymore now there's people
that want to reinstate this whole thing
so they want to go back to tradition
actually is it's they want to have a
traditionalist religion yes God in his
son had been seeking fruit and had found
none Israel was a Canberra of the ground
its very existence was a curse for it
filled the place in the vineyard that a
fruitful tree might fall
it robbed the world of the blessings
that God designed to give the Israelites
had misrepresented God amongst the
Nations
they were not merely useless but it
decided hindrance to a great degree
their religion was misleading and
wrought run instead of Salvation Martin
I'm afraid that many of our churches
today have become useless and a
hindrance yeah because they are
misleading and taking people away from
salvation rather than pointing them to
Salvation
and especially at the point in time
this is pivotal that we do not let the
world come in because that like we said
you are going to be a representative of
Satan if you do this
the more the world goes in the wrong
direction the more we should stand for
righteousness and truth and not go along
with it
we have made it a tradition
to go along with the world
no matter what the subject is whether it
is a work subject whether it is a
medical tradition we have decided that
we will go with the traditions of men
it's time the church wakes up I agree we
should stop and wake up
for the rejection of Christ with the
results that followed they were
responsible a nation's sin and a
nation's ruin were due to the religious
leaders
and if I look at the councils of the
churches these days
and some of the decisions that are being
made by the world churches even by the
Protestant churches
it is so obviously contrary to the word
of God that it boggles the mind that
they call themselves leaders in a
religious world we showed the Church of
England yes that want to create a
gender-neutral Bible
so that's a Protestant church that's a
Protestant church and then that's not
even speaking of well like you said
earlier it's time that our church wakes
up I wish I wish it's a it's a prayer
that we have to
pray continually
Isaiah 9 16 says for the leaders of this
people cause them to ER and they that
are LED of them are destroyed
it's a very serious allegation now we
will see just now that this does not
only apply to Israel of old
more so for us than for them and that's
that word destroyed it's a warning
Maya 5 30 a wonderful and horrible thing
is committed in the land
the prophets prophesy falsely and the
priests bear rule by their means and my
people love to have it so and what will
ye do in the end thereof
only can I
try and explain it this way
the righteousness of Christ
unless you have the righteousness of
Christ
which exceeds the righteousness of the
Pharisees because they only have
self-righteousness
you will not be able to stand finished
because only with that robe will you
enter in
if somebody tries to enter in with
another rope isn't he thrown out
according to the parable
not he sifted out okay
now imagine Christ's robe of
righteousness
is there any room for any form of sin in
that robe no
so if somebody says but let's allow this
inclusiveness within the church isn't
that excluding the robe of righteousness
would Christ wear that compromised robe
no he wouldn't right he cannot he didn't
have any sin so his rope is plot
spotless now the issue of righteousness
by faith
has always been under attack by the
world because it is the one doctrine
that sets through Christianity apart it
is the foundation stone of all true
religion
so let's go to Catholic tradition
this comes from Catholic answers
they write here thus By the Light of the
spirit of Truth
these successes can in their preaching
preserve the word of God Faithfully
explain it
and make it more widely known who are
these successes these are the successes
of the Elders of the Apostles yeah so
they are the ones that are going to tell
you what's going for what not the word
of God
consequently it is not from sacred
scripture alone that the church draws
her certainty about everything which has
been revealed therefore both sacred
tradition
and sacred scripture are to be accepted
and venerated with the same devotion and
reverence isn't that contrary to what
Jesus just said 100 it's directly the
opposite it's directly the opposite okay
but Evangelical and fundamentalist
Protestants by the way fundamentalist
Protestants or people that believe every
word in the word of God so according to
this definition we qualify for that part
I certainly hope so
who press their confidence in modern
Luther's theory of solar script era
Latin scripture alone will usually argue
for their position by citing a couple of
key verses the first is this
these are written that you may believe
that Jesus is the Christ the son of God
and that believing you may have life in
his name the other is this quoting John
20 31. all scripture is inspired by God
and profitable for teaching for a proof
for correction for training in
righteousness so that a man of God may
be equipped prepared for every good work
quoting II Timothy according to these
Protestants these verses demonstrate the
reality of solar script Tira
well if they do not do that then what do
they do that's exactly my question those
two verses is I don't think it's obscure
I think it's plain man does not live by
bread alone but by every word that
proceeds out of the mouth of God
no
so reply Catholics first the verse from
John refers to the things written in
that book
read it with John 20 30 the verse
immediately before to see the context of
the statement in question if this verse
were proved anything it would not prove
the theory of solar script Theta but
that the Gospel of John is sufficient
okay so you just need the Gospel of John
it's a such a ludicrous statement we
don't have to even discuss it well the
problem is this is not only taking root
in the Catholic Church no this only has
spilled over into Protestant churches
correct
all right second the verse from John's
gospel tells us only that the Bible was
composed so that we can be helped to
believe Jesus is the Messiah it does not
say the Bible is all we need for
salvation much less that the Bible is
all we need for theology I thought the
Bible said you weren't allowed to add to
it or allowed to subtract from it isn't
tradition adding to it
exactly and chopping out verses in the
Bible that don't suit your tradition
isn't that taking away from it this is
so horrendous I will get angry so I will
calm down to a panic here but you see
that's what I and again I want to
reiterate this is Catholics speaking
here but this is applicable to
unfortunately Even in our own ranks well
why did they make a queen James Bible
because they weren't satisfied with the
King James Bible right they only took
out a few few words and made it gender
neutral but for the sake of that
tradition
nor does it say the Bible is even
necessary to Believe In Christ after all
the earliest Christians had no new
testament to which they could appeal
they learned from oral rather than
written instruction you know Martin
if it's not in harmony with the with the
law and the testimony then there is no
light in it so this is the most
ridiculous statement Under the Sun just
take the whole
um Plan of Salvation that was
intermingled in the sacrificial system
how do you not exactly what Jesus and
the disciples after it preached and we
are supposed to preach was preached
actually by Israel through that system
yes so my question is do Protestants
fear any better when it comes to
tradition no
do they not hold to the tradition of the
Catholic version of The Commandments
precisely do some partake in the
Eucharist celebration
do they not partake in a communism what
is light and darkness got in common can
one worship two saviors
one that saved us through his blood and
one that saved us through his works one
that died for our sins and one that died
to merely demonstrate ultimate obedience
can one Embrace what the Bible condemns
for the sake of political correctness
and still claim to be the
representatives of Christ
that is a very good question the last
one because political correctness it's
what's ruling at this stage correct
let's just unpack this a little bit
Martin
Catholicism as we have seen here in this
statement says Christ didn't die for you
you are not saved by the blood of the
Lamb
you are saved by your works
and therefore they had to invent
something called purgatory
where you are purged of the guilt and
the punishment of sin
so after you have repented of your sins
and your sins have been forgiven not by
Christ but by a priest
then you must still pay the price so
that when you finally get to heaven you
have actually paid for your own
salvation
so there is no righteousness by faith in
Roman Catholicism there's only your own
righteousness God is a hard task master
who punishes you until you have done
enough to get to heaven even after death
you will roast in purgatory until you
have paid every cent of your debt
now unfortunately that theology is not
only not in the Bible
but it's not logical because the
punishment is death
not roasting until you have paid the
price it is death and which death the
first death or the second death second
death it is the second death the death
of eternal obliteration
now if you take any of the deities in
the world with which we like to sit in
religious communion claiming that all
roads lead to God they all
have tradition
and works-based theology in order to get
to heaven that's it you have to do
pilgrimages you have to do something to
gain favor with God
but the god that we serve the god of the
Bible
who spilled his blood for us who washed
Us in the blood of the Lamb he paid the
price now Martin what price did he pay
the first death or the second death the
second death he had to because otherwise
why would he still die what's the point
of the first death how do we know that
he paid the second death because he paid
the price for us right and didn't he say
on the cross my God my God why have you
forsaken me that's it now if he said why
have you forsaken me where in the Bible
do we read that we are forsaken when we
die the first death no no nowhere
nowhere so only in the second Earth
death will we be forsaken
and if he didn't pay the second death
then we would have no right to heaven we
come to him with filthy rags
we are sinners
Martin have you sinned in your life yeah
there's not one without sin there's not
one without sin and if we had to list
the Commandments I can assure you I
broke every single one
and if you say I never murdered anyone I
certainly did in my head of course I
even said land to murder some people in
my head yeah well even if you are just
angry with your brother without a cause
that's murder that's murder and nobody
on this planet can go and tell me they
haven't had a
thought about being crossed with
somebody all right now just think of
this
just think of this magnificent theology
here I am and I am sentenced to death
and I have
nothing to offer I have no excuse
so all I can do is I can look at the
cross
because there the Press was paid for me
Christ died the corporate man so he died
not only for me he died as me
and if he gives me his perfect robe of
righteousness without spot or wrinkle
then I can stand before God as though I
had never sinned if God looks at me
through the righteous robe of Christ
it's like The Mercy Seat on the Ark of
the Covenant he looks at the
righteousness that Mercy Seat represents
his righteousness okay he looks at that
all right so there's nothing I can do I
cannot repay because the only penalty
that there is is death
Eternal death
but through Christ I can have eternal
life now take any of the deities in the
world
did any of the deities pay the ultimate
price so that that penalty can be
removed from us did let's call them by
name did Allah come and die for you and
for me no no
and what would he do to you
if you do not make it
will put you into eternal hell it will
roast your skin off and your intestines
give you a new one every day so that you
can suffer again the same pain for all
eternity
compare that with the savior
Jesus Christ
who came and paid the ultimate price
took all the abuse
for my sin
and paid the ultimate price without one
tenth of sin upon him
why would I not want to embrace that God
why would I want to put a disease
tradition like purgatory
in the place of the perfect forgiveness
of Jesus Christ why would I want to do
that knowing the scriptures yeah well
that's a problem you're not knowing the
scriptures
okay now when that system Roman
Catholicism becomes the leader of the
religious world and everybody joins
themselves to them and forgive sin like
they forgive sins why they themselves
are transgressors
button isn't that a travesty of Justice
yeah it is but now this links on to
something else as well and if you don't
join in with these movements then you
are the Pariah but that's what I mean so
now what happens
you've got on the one side you will you
will burn in purgatory
now they've actually come up with a
clever other side as well now it's okay
you can still carry on with it because
Jesus loves you
Jesus loves you and therefore whatever
you do is fine Martin if you want to put
on the robe of righteousness
then like Joshua the high priest you
appear before God
with filthy rags
the first thing that has to happen is
those filthy rags must be removed yes
because you will not get into heaven
with those filthy rags also Martin you
cannot wear the pure robe of
righteousness over the filthy rags no
you cannot be an old wine skin with a
new robe on and that is the Crux of this
whole thing that I want to say from the
other side so
if you are a transgressor which all of
us are
and that righteousness comes that Christ
gives then the old must give way he
washes it away and then old wine that
old understanding that old Doctrine
those old traditions those old values
those old uh ways that things that you
do
if you are what must happen to them
why do we want to tolerate them in the
church why cannot we cannot
so Martin unless our righteousness
exceeds the righteousness of the scribes
and Pharisees we will by no means enter
into the kingdom of heaven
I was shown that a terrible condition of
things exists in our world the angel of
Mercy is folding our wings ready to
depart already the Lord's restraining
Powers being withdrawn from the earth
and Satan is seeking to stir up the
various elements in the religious world
Leading Men to place themselves under
the training of The Great Deceiver
who work with all deceivableness of
unrighteousness in the children of
Disobedience already
the inhabitants of the Earth are
marshalling under the leading of the
Prince of Darkness and this is but the
beginning of the end
I wonder what she would have written had
she been alive today
every act however small has its place in
the great drama of life
consider that the desire for a single
gratification of appetite
introduced sin into the world with its
terrible consequences unhallowed
marriages of the sons of God were the
daughters of men resulted in apostasy
which ended in the destruction of the
World by a flood the most trifling Act
of self-indulgence has resulted in great
revolutions
this is the case now there are very few
who are circumspected like the children
of Israel they will not take heed of the
words of counsel but follow their own
inclination
they Unite with the worldly element in
intending Gatherings where they will be
brought into notice and thus lead the
way and others follow
what has been done once will be done
again by themselves and many others
every step this take makes a lasting
impression not only on their own
conscience and habits but upon those of
others
this consideration gives awful dignity
to human life my heart aches day after
day and night of the night for our
churches
many are progressing but in the
backtrack
the path of the just shines more and
more until the perfect day their March
is onward and upward they progress from
strength to strength from Grace to Grace
from glory to glory this is the
privilege of our churches but oh how
different has it been with them they
need Divine illumination Martin are we
in this situation 100 percent we need
this Divine illumination
they must face Square about I know what
I say unless they shall become Christian
indeed
that they will go from weakness to
weakness divisions will increase and
many Souls will be led to Perdition all
I can say to you is
take up the light which God has given
you and follow it at any cost to
yourselves this is your only safety you
have a work to do to come into Harmony
and may the Lord help you to do it even
if self is crucified you cannot bring
sin into the church
no no no there's no space for it the
church must be the filter to keep it out
exactly
gather up the Rays of light that have
been slighted and rejected gather them
up with meekness and with trembling with
fear the sin of ancient Israel was in
disregarding the expressed will of God
and following their own way according to
the leadings of unsanctified Hearts
modern Israel are fast following in
their footsteps and the displeasure of
the Lord has surely resting upon them
it is never difficult to do what we love
to do but to take a course directly
against our inclinations is lifting
across
Christ prayed that his disciples might
be one as he was one with the father
this Unity is the credentials of Christ
to the world that God sent him when
self-will is renounced in reference to
matters there will be a union of
Believers with Christ
this all should pray for and work for
determinately
thus answering as far as possible the
prayer of Christ for Unity in his church
here's another quote from five
testimonies the same Disobedience and
failure which were seen in the Jewish
church have characterized in a greater
degree the people who've had great light
from heaven in the last message of
warning we're worse yeah
what does that tell you
it tells me that we are on the brink of
having
a catastrophe if we don't wake up you
know I'm inclined to pick up the Bible
Martin
I am so inclined to pick it up
just turn to Ezekiel
and you know if you go to chapter nine
it's the chapter about the incorn hmm
and it says he cried also in mine ears
with a loud voice saying cause them that
have charge over the city to draw near
even every man with his destroying
weapon in his hand
and behold six men came from the way of
the higher gate which lieth towards the
North
and every man a Slaughter weapon in his
hand and one man amongst them was
clothed with linen with the writers
incorned by his side and they went in
and Stood Beside the Brazen altar these
are the final moments of Earth's history
this was a type but there is an
anti-time
and the glory of the god of Israel was
gone up from the Cherub whereupon he was
to the threshold of the house and he
called to the man clothed with linen
which had the writers in corn by his
side and the Lord said unto him go
through the midst of the city through
the midst of Jerusalem and set a mark
upon the forehead of the man that sigh
and cry
for all the Abominations that be done in
the midst thereof
and go the others he said in my hearing
go ye after him through the city and
smite let not your eyes spare neither
have pity slay utterly old young both
maids and little children and women but
come not near any man upon whom is the
mark
and begin at my sanctuary and they began
at the ancient men
this is a very serious issue
that's speaking about the church this is
the final ceiling
this is the ceiling that you are sealed
that means you are so settled in the
truth that you cannot be moved and that
will be part of the hundred and forty
four thousand and he saw them coming
behind and slaying
and in verse 8 it says and it came to
pass while they were slaying them and I
was left that I fell upon my face and
cried and said ah Lord God will thou
destroy all the residue of Israel in thy
pouring out of thy Fury upon Jerusalem
Martin are we heading for a terrible
shaking
I think we're already seeing glimpses of
this isn't that terrible
now what was the reason if you turn to
chapter 11.
moreover the spirit lifted me up and
brought me into the east gate and the
Lords of the Lord's House which look at
Eastward and behold at the door of the
gate 5 and 20 men and then I saw
jazzaniah the son of azur and Pelletier
the son of banaya princes of the people
so he's seeing the leaders of the people
together 25 Elders of people of God yes
even our executive committee consists of
about 25 elders just for interest sake
and then said the unto me son of man
these are men that devise mischief and
give Wicked counsel in this city
which say it is not near
beware of people that say it's not near
it's not near the end
let us build houses this city is The
Cauldron and we are the Flesh and the
Lord showed them no no
it'll be the other way around you will
be destroyed
verse 8 it says you have feared The
Sword and I will bring a sword upon you
says the Lord God and I will bring you
out of the midst thereof and deliver you
unto the hands of strangers and will
execute judgment upon you so what was
the problem just look at this verse 12.
and ye shall know that I am the Lord for
ye have not walked in my statutes that
was a serious issue neither executed my
judgments but they've taken the
judgments of the world and introduced
them into the church
but have done after the manner of the
Heathen that are around about you aren't
we taking our example from the Heathen
round about us and bringing all that
those Traditions into the church
it's just interesting in verse 9 that
we've just read and I will bring you out
of the midst thereof that is
the midst of is Jerusalem that's God's
people that's God's people he'll take
them out and he'll destroy them outside
outside so if you are standing outside
you don't have a problem you've gotten
yourself outside of the true church
you know one of the biggest problems
that we have is that people don't
believe
that we are close to the end and they
keep telling you that the time is not
yet and if you dare say the time is near
then they explode
so if you if you turn to chapter 12
verse 22
where it says son of man what is that
proverb that you have in the land of
Israel saying the days are prolonged and
every vision faileth
it's not gonna happen no no no the time
is not yet if you drop down to verse 27
it says son of man behold they of the
House of Israel say the vision you seeth
is for many days to come and he
prophesies of times that are far off
a serious issue Martin a very serious
issue
but Martin it's not time to do a study
on Ezekiel we might do that at another
time the trouble is that the situation
is very similar
that would happen before the destruction
of Jerusalem
surely it was a type
for the destruction at the end that's
exactly if if we see the abomination of
desolation stand where it ought not
that's exactly just before the
destruction and we are at that time
again
so in second selected messages we read
Satan is working that the history of the
Jewish Nation may be repeated in the
experience of those who claim to believe
prison truth
I was pointed back to ancient Israel but
two of the adults of the vast Army that
left Egypt entered the land of Canaan
their dead bodies were strewn in the
wilderness because of their
transgressions modern Israel are in
Greater danger of forgetting God and
being led into idolatry than were the
ancient people
so we are
in more trouble and we have to be so
much more Vigilant yes
if we read the highlighted portion of
testimonies to ministers if we trust in
our own wisdom and strength or in the
wisdom and strength of our fellow men it
will be turned unto poison
the bane of religion isn't the
definition poison that's it death
in the struggle for eternal life we
cannot lean one upon another we have to
have an experimental religion with the
word of God
so let's ask the question again is the
remnant safe from the illusions of the
last days
no we've just read it in Ezekiel as well
okay Martin we had the alpha of the
apostasy in the representation which
passed before me I saw a certain work
being done by medical missionary workers
are ministering breathing we're looking
on watching what was being done but they
did not seem to understand
the foundation of our faith which was
established by so much prayer such
Earnest searching of scripture was being
taken down
pillar by pillar our faith was to have
nothing to rest upon the sanctuary was
gone the atonement was gone didn't we
just speak about that
how can you remove the atonement and
replace it with 40 Rags of your own
works
and unfortunately and Toleration Martin
of that which is wrong
oh that is exactly what is the problem
it's a big difference in wanting to help
somebody
and in telling him it's okay to be
stuck in it
the first requirement is repent yes
and repent means to turn around 180
degrees stop doing what you did
and turn to God
we all have evil propensities but they
have to be overcome yes and they can
only be overcome in Christ
so do you wonder that I have something
to say when I see the pillars of our
faith beginning to be moved seductive
theories are being taught in such a way
that we shall not recognize them unless
we have a clear spiritual discernment
just as long as God has a church
you will have those who will cry aloud
and spare not
will be his instruments to reprove
selfishness and sins and will not shun
to declare the whole counsel of God
whether men will hear or forbear we have
a duty
that this statement tells me that you
cannot just go and sit behind a rock and
hold your mouth no you have to speak up
I view the church in more dangerous
conditions than there have ever been
experimental religion is known but by
few the shaking must soon take place to
purify the church I believe Martin we
are in the shaking
so the shaking is to purify the church
yes and get the people that's not pure
out correct not the pure out all right
what are the problems
well one of them is of course unbelief
in the testimonies
has been steadily increasing as the
people backslide from God
it is all through our ranks all over the
field but few know what our churches are
to experience
I saw that at present we are undivine
forbearance but no one can say how long
this will continue no one knows how
great the mercy that has been exercised
towards us
but few are heartily devoted to God
there are only a few who like the stars
in a tempestuous night shine here and
there amongst the clouds it's a rather
sad picture Martin
that's the state that happened to Israel
as well
so let's read it again we've read it
before Satan is working that the history
of the Jewish Nation may be repeated in
the experience of those who claim to
believe present truth we are in serious
serious Danger
as we're near the end of time falsehood
will be so mingled with truth
that only those who have the guidance of
the holy spirit will be able to
distinguish truth from error now Martin
how do you get the guidance of the of
the Holy Spirit by reading the the Bible
and accepting Jesus as your
righteousness all right doesn't the
bible say that the Holy Spirit was given
to them that obey him in Acts chapter 5.
can you follow Jesus without obeying him
no you can't
so those who are Guided by the word of
the Lord as you have stated will discern
with certainty between falsehood and
Truth between sin and righteousness
now the testimonies
if they are the testimonies of Jesus
then it is his word isn't it definitely
okay
in this time evil angels in the form of
men will talk with those who know the
truth
they will misinterpret and misconstrue
the statements of The Messengers of God
they will twist the words around in your
mouth
have Seventh-Day Adventists forgotten
the warning given in the sixth chapter
of Ephesians
we're engaged in a Warfare against the
host of Darkness unless we follow our
leader closely
Satan will obtain the victory over us
Martin
we have to get our people to become word
based
I think it is probably I know it's my
burden and I know it's your burden that
please people we have to wake up and
start living according to that word and
not let out
stand it down to let all the world's
nonsense get in correct
so there will be apostasis that will
surprise us Martin I'm being surprised
yeah and me too are you being surprised
we shall in the future as we have in the
past see all kinds of character develop
we shall witness the apostasy of men in
whom we had had confidence in whom we
trusted who we supposed was true as
steel to principle that's a rather sad
statement
it's also interesting that they will use
hypnotism isn't that what the serpent
used on Eve of course doesn't Hollywood
qualify for that absolutely
the diamonds come when even in the
church and in our institutions some will
depart from the faith giving heed to
seducing spirits and doctrines of devils
but God will keep that which he is
committed to him let us draw near to him
that he may draw near to us
let us bear a plain clear testimony
right to the point that hypnotism is
being used by those who have departed
from the faith
spiritual formation is hypnotism
neuro-linguistic programming is
hypnotism
and that we are not to link up with them
through those who depart from the faith
the power of the enemy will be exercised
to lead others astray
so as we said spiritual formation
neuro-linguistic progressing mysticism
what about music Martin can that be
hypnotic oh
Hollywood and music the two main things
that Satan uses
to draw us away and what happens both of
them are filtering into the church of
space instead of like you said we have
to filter it out all right we've said
this a hundred times already but you
were in
uh the Rave culture
did they use hypnotic music yeah of
course when you walk into a casino what
kind of music is there there isn't
really music it's like a droning in the
background right
and it's supposed to put you into a
altered state of consciousness so that
your frontal lobe is basically made null
and void so that they can milk you like
they want to they do the same in
churches oh but now that you mentioned
gambling the other thing is the reason
why they make a slot machine to turn
like it does is also hypnotic yeah and
that is they've also Incorporated that
in the browsing of your phone
Tick Tock and YouTube recommended videos
is scrolling down and like a slot
machine every now and then when you get
a nice one it's like oh here's a reward
so they work on the same basis it's all
doing this hypnotic type so how careful
must we be as to how we are influenced
by the media you have to know this is
the main means of Satan to try and get
you away from God's way
and can he plant ideas subliminally into
your mind coming to think of it now
again if you scroll down in your or Tick
Tock I don't use Tick Tock but I've seen
how it works but recommended videos on
YouTube for instance you scroll down on
your phone
sometimes there's a subliminal one that
also videos that come up that has got
nothing to do with what you've browsed
before anything but they
put it there like you just said for a
subliminal for and sometimes it's even
horrific what type of videos that would
be so that's 100 True what you're saying
it's dangerous okay so when Jesus said
that you must take heed that no man
deceives you
there are many fronts on which we have
to beware
what about your stomach
for they that are such serve not our
Lord Jesus Christ but their own belly
and by good words and fair speeches
deceive the hearts of the simple
so is it possible to even be deceived
through what you eat and drink
definitely
let no man deceive you with vain words
because of these things come as the
wrath of God upon the children of
disobedience
so among the danger that threatens our
churches is that new and strange things
will be brought in things that confuse
the minds of the people
and give them no strength at the very
time when they most need strength in
spirit spiritual things
we have a three Angels messages to give
and we are being distracted by the
nonsense of wokeness
by the nonsense of every wind of
doctrine that is blowing within the
church and by the nonsense of tolerating
sin because God is a loving and
forgiving God
you know what it's so sad and then to
put the cherry on top the nonsense of
taking this
messenger and throwing it away
and then all of those things are so much
easier to also bring in this because
then you have to look at it obliquely
and not face it directly
what about there is to be no compromise
with those who are worshiping an idol
Sabbath hmm what does that do to a
commandism
gone
okay
I was told that men will employ every
policy to make less prominent the
difference between the faith of
Seventh-Day Adventists and those that
observe the first day of the week what
if we get a middle ground like climate
change and what if we decide to follow
that lie
and run with the traditions of men then
the Sabbath will be likely regarded
won't it it's already being done
all right Satan hopes to involve The
Remnant people of God in the general
ruin that is coming upon the Earth as
the coming of Christ draws nigh it will
be more determined and decisive in the
efforts to overthrow them
men and women will arise professing to
have some new light or some new
revelation whose tendency is to unsettle
Faith in the old landmarks now the
Sabbath is under attack in more ways
than one it's not only under attack by
those outside the church what does it
matter which day you worship on when God
specifically said the seventh day
but what is the Sabbath day
does it come in a certain cycle that
that we have missed like the moon cycles
does it do this that and the other all
of these things so now you see that's
the problem
so even if you do have the truth and
you've accepted all of this no now the
enemy brings in lots of other doctrines
or things that can take you away yeah
when I look at our Pioneers for example
uh you can take any one of them they
were in the world they were first day
Adventists at one stage and then they
became Seventh-Day Adventists and some
of them even at school
some of our Pioneers who were beaten by
the teachers because they said excuse me
they weren't Advent Seventh-Day
Adventists they said Excuse Me Miss
uh the dictionary says that Saturday is
the seventh day of the week
and you are saying it is Sunday which is
actually the first day of the week some
of them were bitten because of that and
then later when they discovered that the
Sabbath was the seventh day of the week
they embraced it to all of those
Pioneers that came in on that basis are
all of a sudden wrong with some of the
new doctrines
when I looked at those changed
Commandments when I picked up that
pamphlet that
that the man who had brought me to God
had given me and it said they changed
the Commandments
and they're clearly stated the seventh
and the first day of the week I grabbed
the Oxford dictionary and that confirmed
to me what was the seventh day and what
was the first day of the week so all of
these issues are very important
so they want to move the old landmarks
Envision I saw two armies in terrible
conflict
standard of the standard was left to
Trail in the dust as company of the
company of the Lord's army joined the
foe
and tribe of the tribe from the ranks of
the enemy United with the Commandment
keeping people of God this must be one
of the saddest visions of them all
company of the company out of the Lord's
people will leave us
in standard of the standard left to
Trail in the dust
as company of the company from the
Lord's army joined the Foe and tribe of
Detroit from the ranks of the enemy
United with the Commandments keeping
people of God so here are people that
are coming out of Babylon and they're
coming into the church and those that
have had the truth and we're supposed to
stand for the truth and said they had
the truth will leave the truth
it's terribly sad that means sad there
will be a shaking and those that were
your friends and your colleagues they
will be gone
and their place will be taking it the
numbers will not decline but there will
be a changing of the Gods
and
if the people that are not doing the
right thing are leaving
and others that want to do the right
thing are coming in into what they
cannot come into something that's
disintegrated that you left
well isn't it true that before they
leave they will do everything in their
power to bring the world into the church
but this is not speaking of the world
coming into the church but those that
have discovered truth coming into the
church and the people leaving so what I
mean is you are shaken out correct not
you are leaving the church because the
church is Babylon correct an Angel
flying in the midst of Heaven put the
standard of Emmanuel into my hands while
a mighty General cried out with a loud
voice coming to line let those who are
loyal to the Commandments of God and the
testimony of Christ now take their
position
so let's just look at the highlighted
portions of five testimony here there
will be many now as in ancient times who
will hold through tradition and worship
they know not what
God will arouse his people if other
means fail heresies will come in amongst
them which will sift them separating the
job from the wheat so Martin before the
sifting
we must expect the heresies no it's
going to be chaos
are the heresies coming into the church
now yes yes doesn't that imply that the
sifting is not far away exactly now what
will cause the sifting the straight
testimony the straight testimony will
cause the sifting and what will cause
the straight testimony
the loud cry the loud cry and what will
cause the loud cry the persecution that
is coming because of the implementation
of the mark of the beast exactly so when
the mark of the beast is being
implemented then there will come as
sifting and until that time we cannot
judge this church other than to judge
what is wrong within it that's exactly
what scripture and the spirit of
Prophecy is telling us
so as the storm approaches a large class
who have professed faith in the third
Angel's message but have not been
Sanctified through obedience to the
truth abandon their position and join
the ranks of the opposition are they
coming in or going out modern going out
they're going out this is very important
so Martin we've always said don't leave
the ship not everybody is happy with
that
but let's just look at this letter to a
brother M
would be Martin
it could be Brother Martin you're right
Martin take a listen take this seriously
I had an impressive dream last night I
thought that you were on a strong vessel
sailing on very Rough Waters
sometimes the waves beat over the top
and you were drenched with water you
said I shall get off this vessel is
going down
are there many shouting now the vessel
is going down Abandon Ship precisely so
please listen listen and take heed
no said one who appeared to be the
captain
this vessel sails into the harbor she
will never go down but you answered I
will be washed overboard
as I am neither Captain nor mate who
cares I shall take my chances on that
vessel you see Yonder
said the captain I shall not let you go
therefore I know that vessel will strike
the Rocks before she reaches the harbor
you straightened yourself up and said
with great positiveness this vessel will
become a wreck I can see it just as
plain as can be
the captain looked upon you with
piercing iron said firmly I shall not
permit you to lose your life by taking
that boat
the Timbers of a framework are worm
eaten and she is a deceptive craft
if you had more knowledge you could
discern between the spurious and the
genuine the holy and that appointed to
utter ruin what do we need Martin
more discernment
so how do we get it how do we just get
it from the scriptures and the
testimonies we're back to square one
there are two groups within this church
whether we like it or not those that
hold to the testimony
and keep the Commandments and those that
bring in Traditions of men
and despise the testimonies
unfortunately and that will be until the
sifting process is over correct so let's
reiterate this because this is so
important we cannot now step off the
foundation that God has established we
cannot now enter into a new Organization
for this would mean apostasy from the
truth it's a very plain statement so you
know even though you are shocked by what
is happening within the churches
this heresy this apostasy is coming in
so that there will be a shaking you see
the problem is there's a lot of quotes
that are being presented that she didn't
have any confidence in the general
conference anymore yes that was after
the 1888 debacle and it took a
look there's quite a few years that she
said she actually said that but there's
also quotes afterward
that she says faith is restored in it
and then these Quotes come out now this
is in 1905.
so she said we cannot step off the
foundation
here's a quote from testimonies to
ministers John was called to behold the
people distinct from those who worship
the Beast or his image by keeping the
first day of the week the observance of
this day is the mark of the beast John
declares here is the patience of the
Saints here are they that keep the
Commandments of God and the faith of
Jesus Martin this is a very definitive
statement
because it says quite plainly
the observance of this day is the mark
of the beast that's called exegesis yeah
now some of our leaders are saying you
cannot apply exegesis to her statements
only homiletics in other words just for
preaching's sake
but Martin that is a a spurious Doctrine
because either the prophet is speaking
the words of God or is not either he has
the authority of God or he has not it
cannot be half measure if you have to
want to use it as homiletics then you
can decide what is that you have to
adhere to and what not correct where if
it's from God you have to have to adhere
everything to everything absolutely
correct okay ask yourself are there
messages
building up or breaking down
that's the first question are they
urging or coming out
or waiting upon the Lord to cleanse his
church
are they teaching things relevant to the
Three Angels messages or distracting
from them
are they taking the church back to
Traditions forms and ceremonies or are
they teaching the righteousness by faith
those are the questions you have to ask
yourself you can add another one
are you bringing worldly practices into
the church and making them acceptable
when God in his word condemns them yeah
right that's the question
so God has a church upon the Earth who
always chosen people and who keep his
Commandments it is not leading astray
offshoot not one here and there but the
people
the truth is a sanctifying power but the
church militant is not the church
triumphant there are tears Amongst the
Wheat was God leading a people through
the wilderness
was he yes
well
some of them removed by God a lot of
them all right is that a type
yes okay
or did he say
my people come out from amongst them and
didn't you suggest that to Moses as a
test that's exactly what didn't he say
step aside and I will make a new nation
out of you exactly oh that is a
beautiful example and that was a test
right yeah and Moses said no so here we
have exactly the same situation and it's
so easy to look at the apostasy and to
say let's condemn the whole lot and
let's start Martin will will start a new
one with you what do you say with your
Offspring let's go well let's get out of
this church that's going to start our
own thing and we will know how to do it
correct this time no no we won't do that
because the church militant is not the
church triumphant there are Tales
amongst the meat World thou then that we
gather them up was the question of the
servant but the master answered nay
this while you gather up the tears you
root up also the wheat with them
the gospel net draws not only good fish
but bad ones as well and the Lord knows
who are his this is God's Church
leave it to God yes cry aloud and spare
not that's it and tell the house of
Jacob their sins but don't go and judge
because you might be throwing air in to
the wolves
it will be found that those who bear
false messages will not have a high
sense of honor and integrity they will
deceive the people and mix up with their
errors
the testimonies of sister white then use
her name to give influence to their work
and they will twist it that's the thing
they will use it for their benefit
to get their purpose done so imagine the
only way to do this is to read it as it
stands you know it says they make such a
selection from the testimonies as they
think they can twist to support their
position and place them in a setting of
falsehood
so that their error may have wait and be
accepted by the people
that's exactly what they're doing it's
exactly what they're doing and the sad
part is that they trying to get you out
of this body who has to do the shaking
God will do this not the people not the
leaders nobody in the church will do the
shaking the coming or the getting out of
this church God will do
absolutely correct
so to claim that The Seventh-Day
Adventist Church is Babylon is to make
the same claim as the Satan who is an
accuser of the Brethren who accuses them
before God night and day Martin
did Jesus talk against the sins of the
Pharisees yes isn't there a whole
chapter of woes against them chapter 25
yes are all where all the Pharisees lost
no no
just remember that
just remember that the whole church was
in trouble and God said you're in
trouble but they were still the ones
that were saved in there correct by this
misusing of the testimonies souls are
placed in perplexity because they cannot
understand the relation of the
testimonies to such a position as is
taken by those in error for God intended
that the testimony should always have a
setting in the framework of Truth so
underneath this first section over here
is truth
then
it must be in that setting it cannot be
put into another setting so you see the
the testimonies are supporting the Bible
and supporting the truth so if you
misuse these testimonies
you are telling people that actually you
you are sinning because you're
denigrating the truth
all right so the church may appear as
about to fall but it does not fall it
remains while the sinners in Zion will
be sifted out that's pretty plain I
don't know how you can misconstrue that
one okay the chaff separated from the
precious wheat this is a terrible ordeal
as tribe of the tribe comes in and
Company of the company moves out
that's a terrible ordeal because some of
these are your friends some of these for
people that you looked up to
but nevertheless it must take place it
is just part and possible
the issue will be the Sabbath
the mark of the beast the implementation
of the mark of the beast will be the
issue it will cause the shaking
it has not yet been enforced they're
still talking about it are there many
that are in sympathy with the worldly
view of environment and wokeness and all
the nonsense that goes with it yes so
all the apostasy that we read in Ezekiel
is happening yes and is there a council
that is obviously wrong because it is in
harmony with what the world is doing and
not what God has instructed his people
about yes
so I saw that God had children who do
not see and keep the Sabbath they have
not rejected the light upon it
and at the commencement of the time of
trouble we were filled with the Holy
Ghost as we went forth and proclaimed
the Sabbath more fully so that must be
because there is a proclamation
regarding the Sabbath
and this enraged the churches and the
nominal Adventists as they could not
refute the Sabbath truth
and at this time God's chosen also
clearly that we had the truth and they
came out and endured the persecution
with us so this is tribe of the tribe
that will come in while those that have
taken the position of the world will
move out and this will be because of the
Sabbath so we have to wait until that
part for this whole shaking to really
direct and when this works shall have
been accomplished the followers of
Christ will be ready for his appearing
then shall the offering of Judah and
Jerusalem be pleasant unto the Lord as
in the days of old as in the former
years quoting Malachi 3 4 then the
church which our Lord at his coming is
to receive to himself will be a glorious
church not having spot or wrinkle or any
such thing
quoting Ephesians 5 27 then she will
look forth as the morning fair is the
moon clear as the sun and terrible as an
army with banners a Martin
let us not shake before the time we not
supposed to do any shaking we are
supposed to preach the straight
testimony that is our job and yes there
is apostasy in the church and yes some
of it is of a horrendous nature that
does not make the church Babylon
that tells us that the time is near
because the apostasy and the heresy is
coming into the church
to shake the people so that they take
sides distinct sides for or against an
issue may God give us wisdom to hold on
and to be on the ship which will be
taken through to the harbor even though
company of the company will leave
we need prayer let's pray
Heavenly Father
we are living in these terrible times
and the shaking is upon us
the final straw
still has to drop onto the camel's back
and then we will see
who the true ones are that stand for
righteousness and Truth not their own
righteousness not their traditions but
the righteousness of Christ
this is my prayer in Jesus name amen
amen
[Music]
thank you
foreign